bienvenue au tennis-club de plaisir l'un
des clubs les plus importants de notre
ligue
voir le club connu et reconnu dans tout
l'hexagone charger danault et président
du tennis-club de plaisir depuis 1989 le
dirigeant a vu la structure se
transformer depuis sa création en 1972
après avoir débuté avec deux courts
aujourd'hui les 957 adhérents peuvent
pratiquer leur passion sur six courts
couverts 10 courts extérieurs dont
quatre en terre battue semblable à
roland garros qui dit ralentissement du
jeu dit technique qui peut être
développer d'une façon un peu plus et
comment pointu si je perds et tu verras
si voyez donc c'est pour cette raison
que chez terre chanteuse vraiment un
atout supplémentaire pour notre club
pour obtenir des résultats en adéquation
avec son infrastructure le club n'a pas
hésité à recruter cinq enseignants
diplômés détail un directeur sportif une
politique qui payent le tennis club a
sorti de nombreux talents comme mika
llodra qui a fréquenté le club de
plaisir pendant deux ans je ne dis pas
ça parce que chez mon club mais tous les
gens dans nos écoles de tennis il ya des
champions thierry qui sortent tous les
gens nous avons déjà les questions qui
vont disputer les championnats de france
à roland-garros donc là chez notre
fierté plaisir organise également un
tournoi futures doté de 25 mille dollars
avec hébergement des joueurs c'est le
seul tournoi en ile de france de cette
catégorie
hormis évidemment roland garros et bercy
évidemment c'est plus de 800
compétiteurs qui défile on maintienne en
russie les dates du tournoi sont déjà
connus les joueurs s'affronteront du 15
au 24 septembre l'occasion de voir peut
être les futures pépites plaisir oise
qui brilleront sur les courts de tennis
dans les prochaines années